The Dashinator.
Oh, sorry.
>> Listen, Evry.
I want to say something before we can
engage. Okay?
Is it okay with you? Sure. Thank you.
The reason that we can't debate because
you control the narrative and you're
going to put me down as soon as you
don't like what I'm saying, all right?
So, if if you're going to have a real
debate and you're going to you and you
will you've been on this topic for so
long and you know the
you're going to you're going to get the
same answer. So, so if you're not ready
to listen to what
what answer we're going to give you
it doesn't matter you like it or not.
So, don't drop people down, all right?
All right, can I say something to you
now? Yeah, go ahead. Notice how you're
up on on the stage again because I am a
man of second chances, just like my
Lord. He gave me a second chance. I give
other people second chances. I try to
emulate him. You're up here again.
The reason why you were dropped the
first time it's not because I didn't
like what you had to say. As you see,
you just criticized me and I let you
speak uninterrupted. I don't care. I
want to hear you. My problem comes when
you and others are dishonest
when you guys play games
when you guys act like you're dumb or
willfully arrogant and stupid. Not
saying that that's what you are, but you
you you portray that. That is what I
will not tolerate. I respect myself and
my time and the time of my audience too
much. So, going forward, all I ask and
this is for all of you. I ask this for
every guest. This is my I have an I have
four rules. Four. One
be respectful. Two
be on topic.
Three be direct. Four
be honest. If you can do these four
things in unison together
you will be able to stay on the platform
as long as you want. You will be able to
speak as long as you want. That's it.
When you're dishonest, you're out of
here. If you're disrespectful, you're
out of here.
If you're
deflecting to every and going everywhere
all over the rabbit trail, you're out of
here. And if you're dishonest, you're
out of here. So, in your case, you were
dishonest. You asked me the same
question twice.
And when I asked you what was the
question that you asked me the first
time, you refused to answer that.
Dishonesty. So, that's why you were
removed the first time. Hopefully with
this a clean state clean slate, sorry,
and we can start over. You're done? You
you are you should be the judge of who's
going to be honest or dishonest. It is
according to your standard.
>> That's right. Not my standard. That's
correct. Thank you. Thank you for being
Thank you for being honest because you
Listen. When you asked me for first time
what I said what what what what what was
my question, you knew well what what
what what question was. You're just
playing slow and dumb. That's why it was
like crazy.
You could say that you assumed to be the
one to be honest. Are you kidding me?
Now you're going back and telling other
guys, go and rewrite that and clip it
and and and and then you know what my
question was. Go and clip it and you
know it. So, that was my So, just really
quick just really quick. You said you
said you said uh
you said when you read the Quran, do you
read it in English or in Arabic? What
was my answer to that?
>> To be honest with you, you didn't you
just kept quiet and you knew where I'm
going. You knew every Listen, be honest.
>> Notice how you Notice how you started
off that with saying with saying
to be honest.
But that wasn't your honest answer. Now,
if you if you forgot, then that's fine.
But you're you're you're sitting here
lying to us. I'll be quiet.
>> Evry Guys when he asked me, do I read
the Quran in in Arabic or in English?
What did I say? Let's see what the Let's
see if the chat can recall. What did I
say?
>> but your followers there don't Okay. Oh.
Okay, so they heard what I said. You see
what they're saying? Oh, yeah. I heard
so, but
I'm sorry, they're your cheerleaders,
bro. What's wrong with you? Are you
slow? Interesting.
So, it looks like everybody can recall
what I said except you. All your
cheerleaders, they accept your views.
I'm I I Listen,
listen.
>> give them this view. I didn't even give
it to them.
>> kidding me? Evry, come on. Come on.
Don't don't be slow, bro. You know. Did
you hear me say, "Hey guys"? I said
English, right? I didn't I didn't lead
them on. I asked them
What did I say?
And they all said the same It's too bad
you can't rewind it back. I wish I
could. At the end of the At the end of
the day, Evry, you know that at the end
of the day you knew well where I'm going
with this. So, that's why you kept
quiet.
>> How about we How about we start over?
How about we start over? Go ahead.
Build your point. Now, remember, all of
this isn't all of this is in light of
10:94 showing that the Bible is the
authority over the Quran. So, you're
setting up a point. So, go ahead. I'll
let you start over. Let's get somewhere
with this. Go ahead. So, my question is
Yeah, yeah, okay. Thank you. Listen, my
question to you, Evry, since you have
four books lining up you just showed us
that you have four Quran.
You just showed that you were very proud
of it. You should be. You should read
it. But the thing is you should read it
and you should understand because when
you put this game on and saying that the
Bible is the authority of the Bible
Yeah, exactly. But you should read it
though.
You know, this is you know, it's not you
know
Let's go Let's go Let's go on it. You
should read it then just have it and
yourself or maybe I don't know ask some
someone. I don't know. They could
support you then. Listen. My question to
you is Come on, Evry. Are you done?
Okay. Go ahead. Are you done? I'm just
counting my I'm just counting my one
Quran.
>> No problem. Okay, you can count to
three. That's a good thing. Listen. My
thing is to you, Evry. When you read the
Quran okay? Do you acknowledge Do you
acknowledge that when you take one
verse, okay, talking about asking the
the the previous the the Christian the
Jews if you in doubt, do you see it in
the line other other text talking about
the same subject or how do you see it?
That's my question to you. Or do you
acknowledge the tafsir of Ibn Abbas, Ibn
Kathir, all these guys? Do you take this
on on your on your consider
consideration to understand the verse?
That's my question to you.
Yeah, so I do take the Quran in its
context with similar with a similar
topic. Um this isn't the only verse that
says this. There's two other verses that
say the same thing. There's chapter 16
verse 43
>> [snorts]
>> and chapter 21 verse 7. But all three of
these verses say, "If you don't know,
then go ask the people of the of the
book." Right? If you don't know or
believe what Allah is saying, go check
with the people who uh the people of the
reminder, it'll say in these verses or
the people of the scripture. So, same
topic
got other verses saying the exact same
thing. Um yes, I've read the tafsir on
10:94. I've read all of them. A few of
them say different things. A lot of them
give different views. None of their
views contradict what I say. Okay, can
you Can you tell me Can you elaborate
with me even even Ibn Abbas according to
Ibn Kathir, okay? Can you tell me what's
his view on this on this on this topic
about the Jews and the Christian and the
Torah and the Injil? Should we Muslims
I'm asking you a question now. So,
listen carefully, all right? When you're
telling me that you read the tafsir of
what Ibn Abbas Can you elaborate with
me? On 10:94.
>> view? It doesn't have an It doesn't have
a tafsir And and and and and
and and not only
not only this verse. The the other view
about the Jews and the Injil, the Torah,
what is his standpoint on this on Torah
and Injil? Should the Muslim follow it
or
how does he view it? I mean Abbas. Well,
so so when when you talk about Ibn
Abbas, Ibn Abbas has an interesting
view.
He His view contradicts what Allah says.
Allah says, "If you're in doubt, then go
ask the people who've been reading the
scripture before you." Ibn Abbas says,
"Why do you go and ask the people of the
book when you have the Quran that's
undistorted where they have distorted
their scriptures, right?" I'm in order
Hold on. Hold on. I'm not done. Thank
you. Evry, listen. I'm not done.
I'm not done.
>> Okay, okay. Go ahead.
Well, he also believes that the
scriptures are uncorrupted and unchanged
and how no one can change or remove any
letter from Allah's books. That's what
he says.
So, he doesn't believe that you as
Muslims should go ask the people of the
book anything, which is in contradiction
to what Allah says here, which he says
you should go ask the people of the
book. Okay, thank you. So, you're
telling me I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm
sorry. I I you know, I I try not to
laugh. I'm sorry.
>> man. I want you to I I like it. Have a
good I'm not not to be dis Listen, Evry,
to not to be disrespect because I've
seen you with a lot of debaters doing
this many times. Oh, I know our brothers
they gave you this answer. I know that.
But the thing is I want to ask you a
specific question. Evry, when you say
that Ibn Abbas is contradicting what
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is saying,
yeah? That's that's that's what you
said, right? Yeah. How do you know that
Ibn Abbas
is contradicting what Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala said? And not only this, Evry.
Good question.
>> thank you. Go ahead. Go ahead. How do I
know that Ibn Abbas is contradicting
what Allah is saying? Very simple,
brother. Very simple. One, a
[clears throat] contradiction is like A
and not A. You can't have one thing and
then the opposite of that thing at the
same time. Those are That's what is
called a contradiction.
So, you have a Hadith in Bukhari where
Ibn Abbas says for the Muslims
that you shouldn't go ask the people of
the book anything about anything. Right?
You shouldn't go do it. You shouldn't
ask them about anything. The Quran here
says Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, he says
that you are that you should ask those
who've been reading the scripture before
you if you're in doubt about the Quran.
So, Allah says Allah says yes, you are
to ask the people of the book. Ibn Abbas
says, "No, you shouldn't ask the people
of the book." Are those two this Are
those two diametrically opposed?
>> It now is so uneducated, to be honest
with you. Listen, I'm I'm trying to help
you out now, right?
>> really quick.
I answered you.
Okay, so my So, let me just let me lay
out Let me lay out my question again so
that you can get straight to it.
>> Go ahead. My question was, when Allah
says, "Yes, go and ask those who read
the scripture before you. Go ask the
people of the book if you're in doubt
about the Quran."
And Ibn Abbas says, "Do not go and ask
the people of the book about anything."
Is that in line with what Allah says or
is that directly opposed to what Allah
says? Allah says, "Yes, go ask." Ibn
Abbas says, "No, go ask." Are those in
line or is that a contradiction? I heard
you the first time. You don't have to
repeat yourself. It's like what what
what. All right, I'm just one time, it's
okay. Listen.
First of all, what you are doing is
totally opposite of what this how to
understand the verse because when you're
telling me that you are doing your own
tafsir because you First of all, Hold
on. I'm coming to it. Let me land, bro.
Don't Look look. I'm
Remember Remember my four rules. I told
you I told you you can talk as much as
you want as long as you are in the four
rules. Right now, you're breaking number
two. You're not being direct.
>> no no. I need you Hold on Hold on,
brother. I'm going to let you speak.
Just give it a second. I'm trying to
tell you how we can have this
conversation continues.
>> Go ahead. Go ahead. I need you to be
direct. You're not being direct right
now. You're rabbit trailing. Be direct.
Answer my question and then expound
however you want to. But, first start
off with the answer to my question,
okay? Okay, thank you.
>> So, the question is Hold on. No, I don't
need you to
I don't need you to
I don't need you to explain why you're
not answering my question. I need you to
answer my question and expound right
after. You got the floor. The question
is, Allah says, "Ask the people of the
book."
Do not ask Not Muhammad, sorry. Ibn
Abbas says, "Do not ask the people of
the book." Is that a contradiction? Yes
or no? Explain and expound how it's not
if if you're saying no.
>> It But, you have to let me talk. You got
the floor. Be direct.
>> Thank you. Thank you. So, please don't
Listen, what I'm trying to explain to
you is the thing is you do not want to
comprehend this. That's the problem. I'm
sorry. That's the problem. But, I'm
going to try one more time. That's what
That's what I don't I Normally, I don't
engage because I don't control the
narrative.
>> a few more seconds to answer my question
directly and expound or else we're done.
>> Sorry, Ervy. Listen, the way you you
understand the the the the the verse
>> I don't hear any answer to my question.
I'm trying to tell you, so be patient.
That's That's one thing you should
>> Go ahead. Answer the question. It's not
a contradiction. How not? Expound. But,
you don't want to listen, bro. That's
the problem. You you control the
narrative.
>> of saying I'm not here to here to
listen, go ahead and expound. How is it
not a contradiction? Go ahead. First of
all, first of all, Ibn Abbas, he he gave
a tafsir on this verse. He says that
this is not only directed to Muhammad
on a all topic. He only said it's about
his prophecy mentioning in the Bible.
So, this that much you didn't know,
Ervy, because whatever your name is.
Listen, he didn't He didn't say that the
Muslims should confirm all Yeah, you
should type it down and go to get
whatever and search what I'm saying now.
He didn't
Yeah. Listen, he didn't say it's only
about the prophecy of the Prophet
Muhammad
that if they are in doubt of his
prophecy coming, they should answer ask
the previous books because Muhammad is
mentioned in your books, in your Bible,
whatever you you might have today
because it's all up and down for you
guys. So, the thing is when you're
telling us that we should follow all or
we should ask the previous people, it is
not an all matter, all right? That's the
problem, Ervy. So, the thing is that
Okay, thank you. So, the second thing is
Ibn Abbas is telling
The same man is saying I let you I let
you go for a very long time, so let me
cut in here.
So, do you So, you agree and I just need
a simple yes or no on this. You agree
that 10:94 uh Allah tells them tells you
to ask the people of the book at least
about some things, right?
>> If it's in line with the Quran, yes.
>> It doesn't say if it's in line with the
Quran. It says if you doubt that what
the Quran is saying.
>> That's the tafsir, my brother.
>> I'm asking about Allah what he says
here. I'll I'll I'll do it again. Here
it is. Wa- Watch Watch this, brother.
If you're in doubt Excuse me, stop
interrupting me. If you're in doubt
about that which we have revealed to
you, then go ask those who read the
scripture before you. Allah
>> And I told you that the Hold on.
Does Allah say for them to go ask the
people of the book regarding some
things? Yes or no? He He said ask them
about Yes, he did, but it's all about
the tafsir. You don't acknowledge
>> That's all I needed. You don't
acknowledge. Listen, no no. See, that's
the problem, Ervy.
>> Hold on a second.
I want to give you something that you
probably haven't seen yet. This is Sahih
Bukhari
7363. Ibn Abbas said, you ready? Ibn
Abbas said, "Now, remember what you
said. You said Allah said yes, ask the
people of the book regarding some
things. Not everything, but some
things." I'm with you on that.
All right? Now, watch what Ibn Abbas
says. Ibn Abbas said, "Why do you ask
the people of the scripture about
anything?" Oh oh. Allah says, "Yes." Ibn
Abbas says, "Why do you do that?" It's
like Ibn Abbas didn't know the Quran.
"Why do you ask the people of the
scripture about anything?"
"While your book, which has been
revealed by
which has been revealed to Allah's
apostle, is newer and the latest. You
read it pure and undisputed unchanged.
And Allah has told you that the people
of the scripture changed their scripture
and distorted it and wrote the scripture
with their own hands
and said it is from Allah set up for a
little game.
Does not knowledge which has come to you
prevent you
from asking them about anything? No, by
Allah, we have never seen any man from
them asking you regarding what has been
revealed to you. So, I'll Let me ask you
this.
Does Ibn Abbas Does Ibn Abbas discourage
you to ask anything? To ask the people
about the book about anything? Does he
Does he discourage you to ask? Let me
see that Okay, you got to let me talk
now, okay?
>> I'll let you talk. Please answer
directly and expound. Talk Answer
directly and expound.
>> Listen, that's the problem. You get to
dictate how I should speak. That's the
That's the problem, Ervy.
>> You're You're You're darn right. You're
darn right. I dictate how you speak
because if it wasn't for me, you would
be waffling and going everywhere else.
You'd be on a rabbit trail. Do you see
how you're not answering you don't come
up to my life and let's have it and then
let me control the narrative.
>> what You know what you're
Go Go ahead.
I'm I'm going to move to I'm going to
meet you and whatever suits me.
>> to You're going to shut up. Get out Get
out of the stage. You don't belong here.
You don't belong here. You don't belong
here. Take care of yourself. You
embarrassed yourself. You darn right I
dictate how this goes because if I
didn't, you would never answer the
question. You would waffle for 10
minutes uninterrupted saying nothing.
Giving nothing but word salad. That's
what you do. That's what you you guys
do.
Muslims can never answer directly. You
guys can never answer correctly. You can
never be direct to the point. You have
an aversion of answering direct
questions. Duh, I'm going to dictate it.
Here, you have to answer directly and
then you can expound. It's not Let me
expound for 10 minutes first and never
answer your question. It's not here. Not
here.